after more than a year of lockdowns and
travel restrictions
millions of europeans are looking
forward to a well-earned getaway
so what if your next break was more
sustainable a holiday which had a lesser
impact on the environment
as we emerge from the pandemic the
european parliament is calling for a
road map towards sustainable responsible
and smart tourism meps want to see new
measures to reduce the climate and
environmental footprints of the sector
we are not talking only about hotels
restaurants you need to understand the
old chain
where can we slow down or low down
the the impact that we have on earth on
sustainability goals
one way to travel green is to prioritize
rural or agri-tourism
and avoid overcrowding in popular
regions parliament is proposing to
expand the tourism eco label
a scheme which certifies environmentally
friendly accommodation
and tour operators allowing tourists to
sleep with a clean conscience
by far the biggest polluter when it
comes to tourism is transport
parliament wants rail travel to play a
big part in making eu tourism greener
meps are also calling for more eu
support for the transition to cleaner
fuels and alternative forms of transport
to boost a green post-pandemic recovery
parliament wants eu countries to support
tourism through recovery plans and a
temporary reduction in vat for the
sector
the reopening should be part of the eu
kovid 19 strategy
with steps like a common vaccination
certificate
[Music]